Speaker 1: Let's go.
Let's go next to Harry from Columbus, Ohio.
Harry, welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: It's excellent to be talking to
you.
Can you hear me all right?
Speaker 1: I can hear you.
Speaker 2: Thank you.
First, I wanted to mention that you said on
a recent bonus show that you wanted to buy
some sort of sign for the back of your car
to talk to other drivers.
And this is a fantasy I've had as well.
But I would heavily advise against it because
I cannot think of a faster way to get shot
on the freeway.
So definitely, definitely don't buy that if
it's available, please.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
My my idea was, you know, particularly the
texting and driving is such a scourge to society
from miles away on the highway.
You know, you see someone going ten under
in the fast lane.
You know, they're on a phone.
And so I have this fantasy that I unfortunately
have to pass them on the right because they
give me no choice.
You get the you know, it's like they don't
even know how to use a highway as I passed
them on the right.
I would have in my window I would just pull
up next to them and have this LED sign that
would I could like type with a keyboard or
something and it would say, get off your phone,
get out of the fast lane.
And that they would learn I'm acting like
an idiot and then they would move over and
everything would be great.
But you're probably right that it wouldn't
really work out in that way.
Speaker 2: I imagine, you know, people would
buy these signs and there'd be like sort of,
you know, a race war or a racing war between
getting in front of each other to swap messages
like, No, are you doing this now?
You're doing that?
Speaker 1: Well, I think it would be effective
on the side window as much as in the back
windshield, you know.
Speaker 2: Okay.
So to my real question, so do you have any
sort of advice for somebody who is currently
at no reading of books?
I, I never really got into reading in high
school.
I was into read it into reading news articles.
But like, do you have any sort of advice for,
like how to get started in reading?
Because I don't really sit down and.
Speaker 1: It sounds like the issue is because
you haven't regularly been reading for a while,
you wouldn't even really know where to start
in terms of what types of books you would
enjoy.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
I mean, that's a good way of putting it.
Sure.
Speaker 1: Okay.
What topics are generally interesting to you
or what?
What movies or TV shows?
Or have you seen a dot.com documentary that
that you liked?
What sort of things are you into?
Speaker 2: I think the main thing is that
I don't want it to be a waste of time.
Right.
Like I already I have such a little time.
I want it to be books where I'm taking in
the maximum amount of learning about.
I think recent American political history
would probably be like the greatest interest
to me.
Just like, okay, you know, you've got a topic
you.
Speaker 1: Cover and recommendations about
because I don't read those types of books
at all.
So my suggestion would be go to a website
like Goodreads and then just search through
some of the recommendations and the highest
rated stuff.
I'm sure you'll find things that are interesting
to you.
Speaker 2: When you only to make sort of recommendations
for like any like what what types of maybe
authors in general to look for maybe for Tello.
Speaker 1: Okay.
We just lost them.
Okay.
I don't read that genre, so I don't know.
But there will absolutely be recommendations.
I would I would consider checking out good
reads.
Okay.
Let's go to Daniel from Maine and Daniel from
Maine.
Welcome to the program.
What's on your mind today?
And I see that you are self muted.
If you unmute yourself, you will be able to
talk to me.
Daniel from Maine, welcome.
Speaker 2: Air me?
Speaker 1: Yes.
Speaker 2: Excellent.
First time caller.
I'm actually shocked.
I was called on.
Speaker 1: I'm as shocked as you are, to be
honest.
Speaker 2: Excellent.
So I've actually been a viewer for a really
long time.
About ten years now, actually.
So pretty crazy.
Yeah, I started watching when you still had
Louis on the show.
Speaker 1: I saw Louis last night.
You know, we played.
We went to trivia, and we were second to last,
unfortunately.
Speaker 2: Oh, okay.
Well, that's that's pretty cool.
Anyways, so I guess my question today is what
I guess, how do you keep yourself from not
going insane with, with what you do.
You know, I when I watch you break down clips
of these insane, you know, MAGA Republicans
and, you know, spouting their nonsense on
Fox News and stuff like almost sometimes like
I like hearing your input on those things,
but when you replayed the clips before you
give your input, it's almost like sometimes
sometimes I can't even listen to what these
people have to say.
Like it's almost it makes me so sick sometimes
that like, sometimes like fast forward even
their clips just so I can hear what you have
to say about it.
It's just that nauseating, you know what I
mean?
Like.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, it's two things.
It's basically two things.
One, I am, to some degree, desensitized by
the insanity.
And I admit that it's not a good thing.
But when you're exposed to this type of insanity
for a long time, there's a normalization that
takes place.
And I'm working against it.
But I know that I'm desensitized to it to
a degree.
And then number two, I do think that taking
a break from this every single week and then
longer breaks every few months is important.
And so when I'm done producing the Friday
show, I don't even look at news until I start
prepping the Monday show.
So there's like multiple days there where
people will say to me, Did you see this?
Did you see that?
I don't because I'm not even paying attention
to the news on those days.
So I think scheduling that and sticking to
it is really important.
Speaker 2: Okay.
Yeah.
I mean, I guess that's just all it's you know,
for a viewer like me, it's, you know, I can
I can only take so much per day before I have
to, like, literally shut it off because it's
just so just bonkers.
Speaker 1: Like, I totally understand that.
I completely understand that.
No, nothing.
No shame in that, you know?
Speaker 2: Yeah.
You'll you'll play a Herschel Walker clip,
and it's like, I feel like I can only sit
through 15 seconds because it's just so unbelievable.
Speaker 1: So those are those are pretty wacky.
I don't blame you.
They're my friend.
Speaker 2: Yeah.
All right.
I think that's all.
Speaker 1: Okay.
Thank you so much for the call very much.
Appreciate it.
Uh, extremely powerful, powerful stuff.